In the previous section, we did an overview of the script and the assets that we will
be using.
In this section, we will be executing the script.
As we complete portions of this workflow, I will review the completed steps.
So let's return to Maya and begin using the script.
Back inside of Maya, we are now ready to execute the script.
As mentioned earlier, you can technically run this entire script, but we're going to
go through this one step at a time and see what each command does.
The first thing we will do is initialize the script.
Select everything from line 731 all the way to line 1 and execute it.
This will bring everything into memory.
Now let's go back down to line 733 and begin the initial work.
Select line 734 to 741 and execute it.
This will load the plugin and create an output and temp folder if they do not exist.
Now we can start to execute each of the steps.
Scroll down to 743 where it says steps.
From step 1 to 3, this portion of the script will move and transform the rig.
We will not see anything happen in the viewport for these three steps, however, after each
step, a new DNA file will be generated and added to the DNA folder.
Select the entire section for step 1 and execute it.
What this command does is it takes the scale values and applies them to the DNA and then
saves this to a DNA file named scaled.
Once this process is complete, select the entire section for step 2 and execute it.
This takes the translation and rotation values that we have over here and it will apply them
to the DNA.
The DNA file will be named translated DNA.
Once this process is complete, select the entire section for step 3 and execute it.
This changes the up access if needed by rotating the rig 90 degrees and applies this to a DNA
named up access change.
The first step is to initialize the script and create folders.
Select the script from line 1 to 731 and run that part to load everything into memory.
Next, select the script from line 734 to 741 to load the plugin and create the output and
temp folder if they have not been created.
Then we can move on by running step 1 through step 3.
For these steps we will not see anything in the viewport, however the DNA folder will
be populated with new DNA files.
Step 1 will scale the rig.
Select the entire section of this step and run it.
This will scale the DNA based on the values we provided.
The new DNA file will be named scaled DNA.
Step 2 will translate and rotate the rig based on the provided values.
Select this entire section for that step and run it.
The new DNA file will be named translated DNA.
Step 3 will change the up access if needed and rotate the rig 90 degrees.
Select the entire section of this step and run it.
The new DNA file will be named up access change.
Now let's return to Maya and continue.
In Maya we have just finished step 1 through 3 where we moved and scaled the rig.
In the DNA folder we can see the DNA files that were created after each step.
We can now move on to step 4.
This will load the last DNA that was generated which is the DNA file named up access change
and it will save the surface joint positions as a JSON file.
Select and run the first portion of the script to load the DNA into the scene.
Now that it is loaded we can see it over here in the viewport.
Next, run this portion of the script to save the current surface joint positions.
A JSON file will be created and added to the temp folder.
Before we move on let's do a quick review of the steps we just completed.
Step 4 will load the change up access DNA file that was generated from the previous
step.
It will then save the surface joint positions.
Executing the first portion of step 4 will load the metahuman head geometry and joints
into a new scene.
The save surface joint positions command will generate a JSON file and add it to the temp
folder.
Now let's return to Maya and continue.
Back in Maya with the surface joints saved we can move on to step 5.
This portion of the script will update the LOD0 neutral head mesh from provided models.
Run this first portion of the script to add the models into the scene.
If we look in the outliner all of the fitted models have been loaded.
As mentioned earlier, if the mesh mappings in the constants section of the script are
labeled incorrectly the models might not load for this step.
Now let's run this portion of the script.
This will get the old and new mesh positions.
We can now run the saveDNA portion down here to save the new mesh positions to the DNA
file.
This will create a new DNA file named meshDNA.
Let's do a quick review of the steps we just went through before we move on.
Step 5 updated the neutral mesh from the provided models.
The first command of step 5 will add the fitted geometry assets into the scene.
Again, if using this with your own character ensure that the mesh mapping names correspond
to the names of the models as they appear in Maya otherwise they may not load.
The getMeshVertexPositions command will get the old and new mesh positions and then save
the new mesh positions to the DNA.
A new DNA file will be created and named meshDNA.
Now let's return to Maya and continue with the steps.
In Maya, step 6 will update the surface joint positions using the JSON file from the temp
folder for the meshDNA file that was generated from the previous step.
Run the showMesh's command to load the updated meshDNA file.
In the viewport we will see the DNA file has been assembled.
Now to update the surface joints I'm going to position the head so that we can see what
this process looks like once we run the next command.
With this portion of step 6 selected I will execute this and we will see the surface joints
snap to their new vertex positions.
Now run the rest of the script over here.
This will save the changes to the DNA and name it changesFromScene.
Then it will load this new DNA.
Now that it is loaded I'm going to make the display panel visible and in the script editor
I will go to the RecalculateLowerLOD section.
If I go to the display panel and hide LOD0 we will see that the changes have only been
applied to LOD0.
In the script editor run the entire portion of the section named RecalculateLowerLODs
over here.
This will transfer the changes to the lower LODs based on LOD0 and it will save those
changes to the final DNA.
Let's do a quick review of these steps before we move on.
Once we have updated the neutral mesh from the LOD0 head mesh the next step is to update
the joint positions.
Execute step 6 to do this.
The showMesh's command will load the meshDNA file and then the rest of the commands will
load the saved joint positions from the JSON file and then move the surface joints to their
new vertex positions.
This change will only be applied to LOD0.
Run the RecalculateLowerLODs based on LOD0 to transfer the changes that were made to
LOD0 to all of the lower LODs and save the final DNA.
Now let's return to Maya and go over the final steps of this script.
Back in Maya execute all of step 7 to check the results.
This will load the final DNA and assemble a full rig.
This process will take a few moments to complete.
Once this process is complete in the viewport we can see the final DNA.
Let's bring this closer to view.
We can also see that the changes to the neutral have been transferred to all of the lower
LODs.
Now because we are in YUP we will notice that the faceboard is over here and that is okay
because the last portion of the script contains the command that will rotate the rig back
to 90 degrees.
The faceboard controls will still work though.
We can see that these are operational.
Now if we are happy with everything the next step would be to run the export FBX for each
LOD section.
I'm not going to run this portion of the script for two reasons.
The first reason is that the current version of the export FBX portion of the script results
in a mismatch between the body and head skeleton.
To work around this use the DNA viewer export FBX script from the examples folder.
The second reason is that we still need to align the skeleton for the head with the custom
body skeleton for a seamless integration.
Now we could do this by hand or we could use the custom body workflow script that will
do this for us.
Now let's review everything we just covered before we move on to the custom body workflow.
Step 7 will assemble a full rig of the final DNA for inspection and if everything looks
correct it will export FBX for each LOD and apply a material placeholder for all of the
LODs.
As mentioned the current version of the export FBX portion of this script results in a mismatch
between the body and head skeleton.
A workaround for this is to use the export FBX script from the examples folder.
Using the final DNA from this script we will now move on to the next portion of our course
where we will use the custom body workflow script to align the head and custom body skeletons
for a seamless integration.